من جانبيه قال مناسق ومجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي للاتصالات الاستراتيجيه جون
كيربي ان الرئيس الروسي فلازم لم يظهر اي
علامات على انه مستعد لانهاء الحربي في
اوكرانيا
تقديم الدعم لاوكرانيا لتكبير لتمكينها من
الدفاع عن نفسها وتخفي في اثار الحرب على
بقيه انحاء العالم
كير ان روسيا تحاول تدمير البنيه التحتيه
المدنيه في اوكرانيا وحرمان الشعب
الاوكراني من التدفئه والخدمات الهامه
الاخرى مع اقتراب فصل الشتاء
بدورها قالت الخارجيه الامريكيه ان
الولايات المتحده لن تفاوض روسيا من دون
مشاركه اوكرانيه وانها مستمره في دعمها
لكياف
بدوره قال مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني
في تغريده على تويتر ان الطريقه الوحيده
لتسويه الدبلوماسيه هي الانسحاب الكامل
وغير المشروط لقوات الاحتلال الروسيه من
اوكرانيا حسب تعبيره